[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
baden hollweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den
sportstandort von mir wir haben unter
anderem diese themen für sie
sturm auf das stahlwerk in mario voll
greifen russische truppen die letzten
verschanzten kämpfer an cdu-chef märz
reist auf ukrainische einladung nach
kiew
recht auf abtreibung in gefahr in den
usa protestieren frauen weil das oberste
gericht sich möglicherweise gegen
schwangerschafts abbrüche stellt
und der titel in reichweite im
spanischen villareal will liverpool mit
trainer klopp ins finale der champions
league einziehen
die lage in mario pohl hat sich in
wenigen stunden dramatisch zugespitzt
nachdem durch eine feuerpause endlich
zivilisten aus der zerstörten stadt
gerettet werden konnten haben russische
truppen damit begonnen die letzte
bastion der ukrainischen kämpfer im
stahlwerk zu stürmen die ukrainische
seite hätte die feuerpause ausgenutzt um
sich neu in stellung zu bringen julia
schröter berichtet
eine schwarze rauchwolke über dem
stahlwerk gefechtslärm es könnte der
entscheidende kampf seien zwischen jenen
die seit wochen erbitterten widerstand
leisten und jenen die ihn brechen wollen
derzeit läuft ein groß angelegter
angriff auf den industriekomplex des
konzerns am stall mit unterstützung von
bodentruppen panzern und boten vom
wasser aus wir werden alles tun um
diesen angriff abzuwehren
in unterirdischen tunnels halten sich
die ukrainischen kämpfer seit wochen
verschanzt mit dabei hunderte zivilisten
die dort schutz gesucht hatten ein teil
von ihnen konnte in den letzten tagen in
sicherheit gebracht werden nun ist das
unmöglich
auch in odessa hat sich der krieg wieder
mit aller brutalität gezeigt raketen
haben eine große lücke mitten in diesem
wohnblock gerissen bewohner wurden
verletzt mindestens ein mensch getötet
ein teenager
ich habe keine worte für das hier der
junge war ein so fleißiger schüler noch
aus dem keller heraus hat er online die
prüfungen gemacht
die hafenstadt im südwesten ist zuletzt
öfter ziel von angriffen geworden weiter
im osten haben die russen bereits die
kontrolle beispiel berlins dort
versuchen die neu eingesetzten behörden
den alltag zu organisieren
es gilt nun russisches recht die führung
in moskau wird so die einschätzung der
usa schon in kürze versuchen teile der
ost ukraine auch offiziell für sich zu
beanspruchen
wir glauben dass russland die
sogenannten volksrepublik bonn jetzt und
lohans annektieren will schon mitte mai
könnte es nach unseren berichten
entsprechende referenten geben solche
gefälschten abstimmungen werden nicht
als rechtmäßig akzeptiert werden
dennoch groß land will fakten schaffen
nun auch im stahlwerk von mario pohl dem
symbol für den ukrainischen widerstand
der bundeskanzler will weiterhin nicht
in die ukraine reisen auch weil der
bundespräsident dort als unerwünschte
person ausgeladen worden war das
erklärte scholz gestern noch mal im zdf
daraufhin bezeichnete ihn der
ukrainische botschafter als zitat
beleidigte leberwurst cdu-chef märz hat
weniger vorbehalte er reiste heute nach
kiew mathis feldhoff
seinen eindruck der zerstörungen fasst
friedrich merz bewegt zusammen das ist
so furchtbar sagt er nach dem blick in
eines der zerstörten gebäude
hinein fort von kiew ist die erste
station von märz bei einer reise in die
ukraine hier erzählt ihm der
bürgermeister wurde der vormarsch der
russischen truppen gestoppt
2000 zerstörte häuser
1500 weitere unbewohnbare wohnungen
zeigen die hinterlassenen verwüstungen
ich bin voller trauer über die
zahlreichen opfer die es hier gegeben
hat aber auch gleichzeitig voller
bewunderung über das was die armee was
die ukrainischen soldatinnen und
soldaten hier geleistet haben die reise
des cdu-vorsitzenden wird begleitet von
viel kritik er wollte sich profilieren
schimpfen koalitionspolitiker der
kanzler hatte die kurze stippvisite
dagegen gebilligt für märz ist auch eine
reise die seine strategie stützen soll
die regierung in berlin zu treiben bei
der lieferung von waffen sei das schon
gelungen jetzt gehe es auch um den
wiederaufbau
ich denke wir sind in deutschland auch
weiter verpflichtet diesem land zu
helfen und gerade einer solchen stadt
wie ihre pin auch beim wiederaufbau zu
helfen nicht nur bei der militärischen
verteidigung sondern auch bei dem was
jetzt hoffentlich folgt nämlich die
wiederherstellung auch dieser stadt und
der möglichkeit in dieser stadt zu leben
und zu arbeiten und auch zu wohnen am
nachmittag traf merz dann den
ukrainischen parlamentspräsidenten und
auch ein gespräch mit präsident sie
lenski wurde kurzfristig anberaumt und
wir katrin eigendorf in kiew dazu wie
erleben sie diesen besuch von friedrich
merz
also die deutsche reisediplomatie und
das ringen darum das ist hier kein thema
für die ukraine aber friedrich merz muss
man sagen ist hier schon willkommen
jeder der sich hier versucht ein bild
vor ort zu machen jeder der die chance
bietet für die ukraine international
einzutreten der findet hier offene türen
im moment stehen wir hier gerade im
hinterhof des rathauses friedrich merz
spricht jetzt gerade mit witali
klitschko und was wir hören an
reaktionen der ukraine sagt man dass man
durchaus diesen besuch willkommen hält
also dieses argument der
selbstinszenierung das sieht hier
niemand so und ich denke man muss auch
sehen es ist wichtig für einen politiker
wenn er für die ukraine eintritt sich
hier ein bild vor ort zu machen da wenn
man das mal wirklich gesehen hat dieses
ausmaß der zerstörung das ist ein ganz
ein anderer eindruck man selber hier ist
als wenn man es im fernsehen sieht die
ansetzung von katrin eigendorf live aus
care vielen dank dafür
von kiew jetzt nach meseberg in
brandenburg zwei tage gehen der kanzler
und sein kabinett dort in klausur
bestimmendes thema natürlich der ukraine
krieg und seine folgen zu gast sind die
regierungschefinnen finnlands und
schwedens beide länder erwägen
angesichts der weltlage einen beitritt
zur nato
ines trams berichtet
es hat etwas von einem ausflug aufs land
kabinettsklausur auf schloss meseberg
doch der krieg in der ukraine
überschattet die idylle die folgen des
krieges wollen sie diskutieren auch
welche belastungen er zusätzlich zum
klimawandel für die deutsche wirtschaft
bedeutet deshalb wird es so sein dass
wir mit wissenschaftlern darüber
diskutieren was das für das ökonomische
modell unseres landes bedeutet wie wir
sicherstellen können dass in zehn
zwanzig dreißig jahren wir noch gute
arbeitsplätze haben trotz all der
herausforderung für den wird stehen die
zeitenwende in der sicherheitspolitik
diskutiert das kabinett genau wie die
innenpolitischen folgen des krieges von
400.000 geflüchteten aus der ukraine
weiß man die dunkelziffer sie liegt
höher wir haben 40 prozent davon kinder
die hierher kommen in unser land und das
führt natürlich dazu dass wir ganz ganz
viele anstrengungen bemühen müssen damit
die sich hier auch zu hause fühlen zum
einen haben wir dafür gesorgt dass die
menschen hier schutz bekommen zum
zweiten dass sie eine arbeitserlaubnis
haben einen sofortigen
arbeitsmarktzugang
eingeladen hat scholz die
regierungschefin den von schweden und
finnland russland überfall auf die
ukraine hat in beiden ländern starke
bestrebungen ausgelöst der nato
beizutreten
russlands angriff auf die ukraine hat
unser sicherheitsumfeld komplett
verändert es gibt kein zurück wir sehen
nun klarer wo russland hin will es ist
eine welt von einflusssphären in der der
stärkste das sagen hat
kanzler scholz sagt finnland und
schweden die unterstützung der deutschen
bundesregierung zu sollten sie sich für
einen beitritt zur nato entscheiden
ein neues das mittlerweile sechste
sanktionspaket gegen russland will die
eu morgen präsentieren an den details
fällt heute die eu kommission in
straßburg
beim heiklen thema öl embargo deutet
sich möglicherweise ein kompromiss an in
form einer gestaffelten übergangsfrist
je höher die abhängigkeit von russischem
öl wie zum beispiel bei ungarn oder der
slowakei
desto länger könnte dort russisches öl
fließen
weltweit behindern gewalttätige
konflikte und staatliche repressionen
immer mehr die arbeit von journalisten
und journalistinnen
das ist das fazit der organisation
reporter ohne grenzen zum tag der
pressefreiheit heute auch deutschland
fiel zurück hier gab es im vergangenen
jahr mindestens 80 gewaltsame angriffe
vor allem bei demonstrationen besonders
schlecht steht es um die pressefreiheit
eben nordkorea sowie in china und
afghanistan
in russland sei sie inzwischen praktisch
abgeschafft christiansen berichtet 100
razzia bei der wochenzeitung list dog in
der stadt corneau anteils investieren
wegen ihrer berichte über die sogenannte
militär operation in der ukraine ist
auch die 23 jahre alte regionalzeitung
ins visier des staates geraten der
gründer sitzt in untersuchungshaft
chefredakteur viktor flüchtete nach
georgien in der redaktion haben sie die
gesamte technik beschlagnahmt und die
ausgabe in der druckerei
die arbeit als journalist in russland
ist oft bedrohlich manchmal sogar
tödlich reporterinnen und reporter
landen im gerichts käfig werden den
augen des staates fake news über die
russische armee verbreitet dem drohen
hohe geldstrafen oder bis zu 15 jahre
haft bestimmte begriffe sind verboten
zensur in russland gibt es kein einziges
unabhängiges nicht staatliches machen
millionär hier ist der informationsraum
auf hochglanz komplett gesäubert
auch der kreml kritische sender tv doch
musste anfang märz das enden einstellen
die journalistin flüchteten ins
benachbarte georgien jetzt soll der
populäre sender außerhalb von russland
weiter leben wir beschlossen dass wir
unseren familien und zuschauern
nützlicher sein würden wenn wir in
freiheit sind und die arbeit von
irgendwo anders fortsetzen und nicht aus
russland anstatt im gefängnis zu landen
über die propaganda in den staatsmedien
hat wladimir putin die meinungsbildung
fest im griff die pressefreiheit steht
zwar in der russischen verfassung aber
im russland von heute existiert sie
nicht mehr
es gibt auch vorbilder beim thema
pressefreiheit in unserer zdf heute app
zeigen wir die spitzenreiter außerdem
finden sie mehr von reporter ohne
grenzen zur lage in den verschiedenen
ländern
jetzt eine überraschende personalie aus
bayern csu generalsekretär stephan mayer
ist zurückgetreten offiziell aus
gesundheitlichen gründen allerdings soll
mayer auch einen journalisten beleidigt
und massiv bedroht haben der 48 jährige
war erst seit februar
generalsekretär stefan leifert in
münchen was bedeutet dieser rücktritt
für die csu und für ministerpräsident
söder er für markus söder ist das ein
politischer gau und ein rücktritt der
völlig zur unzeit kommt stephan mayer
war gerade mal drei monate im amt und
war der wichtigste teil an der
personellen neuaufstellung die markus
söder gerade vorgenommen hatte er sollte
als generalsekretär den
landtagswahlkampf managen der für die
csu ihr nächstes jahr ansteht und bei
dem es für die csu um den machterhalt
und damit um alles oder nichts geht
csu-generalsekretär meyer sollte die
partei neu aufstellen er sollte mit
seinem konservativen profil dafür sorgen
stammwähler der csu wieder stärker
anzusprechen und er sollte markus söder
das profil des treusorgenden
landesvaters verpassen für die csu
mitglieder auch prominente kommt das aus
völlig heiterem himmel alle mit denen
wir kontakt hatten sind fassungslos aber
offenbar waren die drohungen die meier
gegenüber journalisten ausgesprochen
hatte zu schwerwiegend parteichef markus
söder will sich erst morgen zu der
personalie äußern aber fest steht schon
heute für ihn ist das ein ziemlich
herber rückschlag dann kam nach münchen
stefan leifert und
gegen den früheren csu
bundesverkehrsminister steuer ermittelt
jetzt die staatsanwaltschaft in berlin
es bestehe der anfangsverdacht
dass scheuer und sein staatssekretär im
maut untersuchungsausschuss des
bundestags bewusst wahrheitswidrig
ausgesagt hätten heuer hatte damals
erklärt nach seiner erinnerung habe es
kein angebot der designierten betreiber
gegeben die pkw maut so lange zu
verschieben bis das urteil des
europäischen gerichtshofs vorliegt der
hatte die maut 2009 10
mit sind die usa dort schlägt ein
eigentlich geheime entwurf aus dem
obersten gerichtshof hohe wellen demnach
könnte das recht auf abtreibung bald
kippen das papier aus dem das magazin
politico zitiert fast offenbar die
meinung der konservativen mehrheit im
supreme court zusammen nach der
veröffentlichung gab es vor dem gericht
in washington proteste laut umfragen
sind die amerikaner überwiegend für ein
recht auf abtreibung
mrt wissen ist vor dem obersten gericht
in washington immer was bedeutet es wenn
der supreme court tatsächlich das
abtreibungsrecht kippt
ja wenn das urteil wirklich so kommt
dann können die bundesstaaten die
gesetze in kraft setzen die sich schon
parat gelegt haben etwa die hälfte der
bundesstaaten will das abtreibungsrecht
massiv verschärfen schwangerschafts
abbrüche beispielsweise ab der sechsten
woche dann schon unter strafe stellen
vielleicht sogar komplett verbieten aber
dieses urteil geht wenn es so kommt weit
darüber hinaus es stellt an einigen
stellen im text eben auch das recht auf
private entscheidungen auf privatsphäre
infrage also einzelne bundesstaaten
könnten zum beispiel entscheiden ob sie
verhütung illegal machen ob sie
gleichgeschlechtliche partnerschaften
unter strafe stellen auf diese gefahren
hat präsident biden vorhin in einer
ersten reaktion hingewiesen also es
droht eine weitere polarisierung im land
aber auch eine mobilisierung für die
wahlen weil amerika ich glaube das kann
man sagen am scheideweg steht ob es die
individuellen freiheiten verteidigen und
auch noch stärken will oder ob es sie
zurück drehen will in einer zeit von vor
einigen jahrzehnten dankeschön
washington m at wissen und wir bitten
die kurzen technischen aussetzer zu
entschuldigen am deutschen arbeitsmarkt
geht es weiter bergauf wie fast immer im
frühjahr und dank gelockerter corona
maßnahmen der ukraine krieg bremst
bislang nur wenig im april waren rund
zwei millionen
309.000 menschen ohne job 53.000 weniger
als im märz die quote sank leicht auf 5
prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr gab es
462.000 weniger arbeitslose verzweifelt
gesucht werden auszubildende weiß stefan
schlosser
das klappt doch schon ganz gut für den
tonnenschweren bagger brauchte es vor
allem konzentration und geschick die
jungen mädchen dürfen an diesem
schnuppertag auf der baustelle alles
ausprobieren
immer mehr junge menschen wollen
studieren immer weniger eine ausbildung
machen mit beginn des letzten
ausbildungsjahres blieben über 63.000
stellen unbesetzt so viele wie seit 30
jahren nicht das hat im wesentlichen
zwei ursachen zum einen regional dass
die jungen menschen in anderen regionen
sitzen
dann sind die berufswünsche
unterschiedlich zu den angebotenen
ausbildungsplätzen und als drittes hast
du manchmal der anforderung der
unternehmen und die schutzliste von
menschen nicht zusammen viele
handwerkliche berufe haben zudem ein
schlechtes image schmutzig körperlich
anstrengend nicht gut bezahlt und kaum
perspektive hier gelte es aufzuklären
die aufstiegschancen in eine ausbildung
nach einer ausbildung sind bedeutend
größer und auch die möglichkeiten gutes
geld zu verdienen sind für einen
qualifizierten der sich weiterbildet und
nicht studiert hat oft größer als einer
der studiert hat was auf einer baustelle
passiert davon haben die jungen mädchen
jetzt zumindest eine vorstellung und
auch das unternehmen profitiert seit sie
hier praktikums tage anbieten haben sie
fünf auszubildende gefunden
heftige unwetter gab es in teilen
spaniens in der ferienregion murcia im
südosten kam es nach starken regengüssen
zu überschwemmungen dort hinterließ auch
ein tornado seine spuren air knickten
zahlreiche bäume um in alicante ging
hagel nieder
alles weiß winterimpressionen im
jetzt zum fußball norbert da verschaffte
die uefa heute wegen des ukraine kriegs
die sanktionen gegen den russischen
fußballverein russland darf sich weder
für die em 2008 und 20 oder 2032
bewerben noch an der nächsten league der
frauen em im sommer und an den
europäischen klubwettbewerben teilnehmen
etwa der champions league ja und da
spielt heute abend villarreal gegen
liverpool das team von jürgen klopp nach
dem 2 0 im halbfinal-hinspiel mit dem
besseren karten
diese jungen herren sind aus dem
nordwesten englands angereist um den
europäischen kontinent zu erobern wir
wollen die brücke war bald klar wir
wollen jetzt ins endspiel aber wenn die
aareal sich gegen uns ins finale spielt
dann meinen herzlichen glückwunsch
variations schwer zu glauben nach wie
areals auf zu dem hinspiel bei zwei
gegentoren und nicht einer eigenen
echten torschuss können die spanier nur
noch auf ihren baskischen trainer hoffen
denn mary wird gerade in schwierigen
momenten an goldenes händchen nachgesagt
vielleicht ja auch heute wieder wenn
ihnen villarreal eine euphorische gelbe
wand auf die englischen gäste wartet
fußball bundesliga zwei spiele gestern
abend leverkusen nach dem 2 2 gegen
frankfurt weiter auf
champions-league-kurs mitkonkurrent
leipzig dagegen titelaspirant im
dfb-pokal und europa league patzt in der
liga und verliert 1 zu 3 in gladbach
der tanz auf drei hochzeiten gerät für
leipzig aus dem takt da hilft auch kein
rot gegen gladbach enis notbremse 64
minute gegen leipzig and conquer den
torschützen zum zwischenzeitlichen 1 1
gladbach seit langer zeit kämpferischer
noch vor der pause das 2 1 durch jonas
hofmann
eine ganz ganz schlechte erste halbzeit
in der wir ja vieles haben vermissen
lassen was du hast brauchst du so ein
spiel zu gewinnen und dann gar das 3 1
durch den doppeltorschützen hofmann in
unterzahl gegen leipziger die aufpassen
müssen dass sich diese leistung im
halbfinal rückspiel der europa league in
glasgow nicht wiederholt
leipzig jetzt tabellen fünfter und damit
nicht mehr auf einem champions league
rang die höhepunkte und vor allem alle
tore dieses 32 spieltag sie können sie
sich bei uns noch mal ganz in ruhe
anschauen bei zdf heute.de und in der
zdf- heute- app
35 tore sind insgesamt zu bewundern
bewundern ist jetzt auch ein echter und
ein seltener schnappschuss aufgenommen
bei garmisch garmisch partenkirchen
dieser braunbär tapste da in eine
fotofalle ein unfreiwilliges 11
eigentlich gibt es die pelzigen
raubtiere in den alpen meist im
italienischen trentino aber manchmal
streifen junge männchen auf weibchen
suche sehr weit umher möglich also dass
nun eines ausbüxte mit einem bärenhunger
auf gesellschaft
das wetter bringt morgen im süden
gewitter die details hat gleich in italy
das heute journal mit christian sievers
um viertel vor zehn danke für ihr
interesse und sie sich noch einen
schönen abend und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ja heute hat es gebrodelt im
süden deutschlands das ist der
satelliten film von heute und was sie
erst einmal sehen sind hier einige
wolkenfelder durch aus auch kompakter
aber im tagesverlauf hat es dann etliche
quellen gegeben vor allem über den
mittelgebirgen sehen sie hier ziemlich
viele wolken oder sind schauer und
gewitter die sich nur langsam bewegt
haben entsprechend hat es örtlich
ordentlich geschüttet in der nacht
lassen die letzten schauer im südwesten
und an den alpen nach ja und richtung
nordosten da klar dass größtenteils auf
uns wird ziemlich kalt richtung finnland
an der ostsee minus ein grad in der
norddeutschen tiefebene um null grad und
9 grad plus richtung rhein main gebiet
morgen dann im süden erst einmal wieder
ähnliches wetter wie heute mit
sonnenschein dann brodelt es erneut
schauer und gewitter teils starkregen
bis 20 liter auf den quadratmeter in
einer stunde ist möglich nach norden hin
bleibt es trocken bei höchsten
temperaturen von 11 bis 14 grad an der
nordsee und 22 grad im rhein-main-gebiet
ja die nächsten tage am donnerstag noch
durchwachsen beim 14 bis 20 grad und
freitag etwas ruhiger ein schöner abend